a doctor who says there's a way we could  actually live past 100 find out how on  the next Oprah are you a snake oil  salesman the angels exist and are they  sending messages help us heal or are you  a reasonable clinician behind the  medical celebrities of Deepak Chopra and  dr. oz is a contentious decades-long  strategy to promote alternative medicine  to the American public how the National  Institutes of Health took an assortment  of mystical therapies from the  fraudulent fringes of the marketplace  and planted them right in the heart of  the american medical establishment is a  story of institutional failure a few  vials of bee pollen thank you very much  and an overdose of political ambition  new schools better health care for our  citizens that's the American dream  you